bombardement accramatork c'est
constructions ont été frappées par
l'armée russe quelques minutes à peine
après la fin du cessez-le-feu décrété
par le Kremlin dimanche le ministère
russe de la Défense a revendiqué ses
attaques le commandement du groupement
combiné des troupes russes amené une
opération de représailles suite à une
frappe massive de missile sur des sites
de déploiement temporaires des forces
armées ukrainiennes à cramatorzek plus
de 600 militaires ukrainiens ont été
tués
un lourd bilan censé contrebalancer
celui du bombardement mené par Kiev à
maquiller au Nouvel An la Russie avait
reconnu 89 morts dans cette ville située
en territoire prorus mais à cramatorze
aucune trace de victime selon les
autorités locales simplement des dégâts
sur des bâtiments vides et des habitants
réveillés en sursaut par les impacts
il y a une explosion puis une autre les
fenêtres ont trembler il y a une série
d'explosion rien de plus dire c'est une
journée normale
les explosions étaient très puissantes
elles ont tiré les gens hors du lit
certains se sont rongés les ongles
importe parole de l'armée ukrainienne a
dénoncé une opération de communication
destinée à masquer les échecs militaires
de la Russie dans l'est du pays